The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: There's a reading.
The new reading is on Stellar.
It's an excerpt from a textbook
on dynamics by Professor Jim
Williams who was in the
mechanical engineering
department here at MIT
and just recently retired.
This reading is essentially
a review of everything
we've done in kinematics.
So it gives you a
different point of view.
It's extremely well written.
So it goes through
things like derivatives
of rotating vectors.
It has three or four really
terrific examples of problems
that are solved using the
techniques that we've used up
to this point.
So it's a good way to
review for the quiz, which
is coming up a week from
Thursday, on October 14.
That quiz will be here,
closed book, one sheet
of notes, piece of paper
both sides as your reference
material.
OK, survey results.
So you have p set four.
It has I think five
questions on that.
We'll quickly take a
look at the problems
that you're working
on right now.
So here's this yo-yo
like thing, a spool.
There were some questions on nb.
The inner piece doesn't rotate
relative to the out piece.
It's all one solid spool, but
it has two different radii that
are functioning in the problem.
And the question is, will
the spool roll to the left
or to the right when the
string is pulled to the right?
So we're going to
come back to it.
I'm just going to run through
all the questions quickly.
The second one was this
somewhat familiar problem
you've done now.
The question asks
you about how fast
it has to go before the
thing starts sliding up.
And the survey question, if the
starting position of the spool
is moved down the rod,
will the angular rate
be higher when spool
begins to slide up the rod?
Will you have to go
faster to get it to go?
OK, next.
OK, this is finding the equation
of motion for a pendulum.
And everybody knows
the natural frequency
of a pendulum's square
root of g over l.
But this pendulum has a
torsional spring added to it.
And the question is, the
square root of g over l
doesn't involve the mass.
But will the natural
frequency, now
that you've put the torsional
spring on it, will it now
involve the mass?
No reason you should know this.
You've never done
this problem before.
And we'll come back to that.
Next.
The fourth problem.
Two degree of freedom system.
And wants you to come up
with the equation of motion.
But the survey question,
if k1 didn't exist,
this is just two masses
coupled by spring,
this thing is no longer
constrained in the x direction.
There's no x constraints
on the system.
So if that's the case,
this system still
has two natural frequencies.
A system that can
vibrant essentially
has as many natural frequencies
as it does equations of motion.
This one requires two
equations of motion,
but it will have one 0 natural
frequency and the other one
greater than 0.
In the second case when
it's greater than 0,
this thing is
oscillating somehow.
It has no extra strength.
What can you say about the
position of the center of mass?
So click at the results.
So this is the first one
is the spool problem.
There's the spool.
Here's table.
Here's the inner radius.
It's got a string wrapped on it.
You're pulling the string this
way at v in the i direction.
This'll be o xy.
And now the question is,
when you pull on this,
which way will the spool go?
And most of you said
it will go to the left.
So I made this up.
We're going to do
the experiment.
So I've wrapped Teflon
tape on this spool.
It's got a C battery
in the center
to give it a little
bit of weight.
And here's the experiment.
And the guys in the booth
I hope have in a minute
to zoom in on it.
I'm going to let go and
I'm going to start pulling.
Oops.
I need to put a
little more out here.
Pull on the tape.
You believe it?
So I've done the reverse
of what's in there.
I'm pulling that way.
But it goes in the same
direction as you pull it.
So the answer to this question
is, it would go to the right.
Kind of unbelievable
almost, right?
How does it do that?
Let's do it again.
All right.
Now, show you something else.
If that hasn't
boggled your mind.
Then what's it going to
do if I pull straight up?
How many think it's
going to go that way?
Raise your hand.
How many think it's
going to go that way?
Raise your hand.
All right.
Sure enough.
That means it must be some
angle between in which
it will do neither.
It'll start to slip.
Right about there.
Neat little problem.
And now doing this problem is
all about computing velocities,
using concepts like.
So if we call this a, b, c.
I think it's the other
way around in the problem.
Excuse me.
A, b, c, and d.
The key to this problem is
being able to figure out
what the velocity
of this point c is.
And the first thing
to understand,
this is the velocity of the
end of the tape in a fixed
reference frame.
So every point on the tape
moves at the same speed.
That means where it
touches right here
is also moving at that speed.
So the velocity of c with
respect to o is to vi.
And that's kind of the
key to the problem.
That's also equal to the
velocity of d with respect
to o plus the velocity
of c with respect to d.
And the velocity
of d is this point
of contact with the ground.
What's that velocity?
0.
This is back to those
instantaneous center
of rotation things.
0 there is what makes
this equation easy.
And then you know how to compute
the velocity of a rotating
vector.
This one's not changing
length, but it is surely
rotating about
this point, and so
there's going to be
an omega cross r here.
And that'll allow you
to solve for omega
and then once you know
for omega then you
can solve for a, which is the
real question that was asked.
OK.
Next one.
So the starting position,
this is a spool.
There's the arm.
And here, the question is
at 0.25 meters up here.
And if you move it
down to 0.15 will
the system be able to go faster
before it breaks loose or not?
And your answer was
most people said yes.
And basically that's true.
What is it that's
driving that thing,
providing the force
that is trying
to push it up the sleeve?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the rod
as it's going around
is trying to drive
that thing in a circle.
And therefore, it
is being accelerated
to the central points.
So it has centripetal
acceleration.
And that requires forces and
they come through the rod.
And that will develop the
normal forces and friction.
So when you slide down the
rod some to that new position,
is has that centripetal
acceleration gone up or down.
r's gotten smaller.
Centripetal acceleration is?
r omega squared, right?
So you might be
speaking algebraically.
So the magnitude of that
centripetal acceleration
has gone up or down if you
bring it closer to the axis.
Down.
So you can go faster to
get up to the same level
of acceleration or
it'll break free.
Next.
This is, oh, the natural
frequency of the pendulum.
Some of you said yes, some of
you said no, some not sure.
You're going to find out.
You're going to figure
out the equation of motion
of the system.
And it includes that torsional
spring and mass is definitely
going to be in it.
So look for an answer
that includes--
that you'll see that mass
is going to show up in a way
that if you solve for
the natural frequency,
it won't leave the
final equation.
OK.
So this is the one
about the two masses.
And if the spring were 0,
the second natural frequency
of the system.
The first natural
frequency, when
you have a system
that has what's
called a rigid body
degree of freedom.
When this thing went,
there's no k1 spring.
This system looks like two
masses on wheels connected
by a spring and a dashpot.
And in the x direction,
there are no constraints.
So if I set this
system to vibrating,
what can you say about the
motion of its center of mass?
So could you find the center
of mass of that system?
Got to give you
the masses of it.
But you have some m1 and an m2.
And we'll call this the
x in that direction.
Could you determine the
center of mass of the system?
You know how to do that, right?
If they were equal in mass,
it'd be in the center.
If this was bigger, it'd be over
here or something like that.
So we know that for a
system of particles,
the sum of the external
forces on the system
is equal to mass of the
system times the acceleration
of the what?
Center of mass.
What are the external forces
in the horizontal direction?
How big are they?
0.
Therefore, what can
be the acceleration
of the center of mass?
0.
This thing will actually in
this second natural frequency,
it'll sit there and just
oscillate back and forth,
one mask on one directional,
one on the other.
But its center of
mass won't move.
The other degree of freedom and
the other natural frequency,
the one that has 0
natural frequency,
is a rigid body motion.
No relative motion.
Give this thing a little
push, some initial momentum,
it'll just sit
their role forever.
The mass is not moving
relative to one another.
It just rolls and rolls
and rolls and rolls
and never comes back.
Infinite period 0
natural frequency.
OK, we were talking
about fictitious forces
the other day.
And there are times
when they're useful.
But they're sort of like giving
a little kid a loaded gun.
You really get yourself
in trouble quickly.
So I'm not advocating
a lot of use of it.
But it's good to have
a little insight.
One of the students after
the lecture last time,
a student mentioned
to me, he said,
the way I was taught
about fictitious forces
is that we use them to
patch up a problem when
we're trying to work in
a non inertial frame.
How can you make Newton's
laws apply if you
are in a non inertial frame?
Otherwise an accelerating
reference frame.
So I just thought I would
revisit a little bit of what
we said the other day with
explaining things that way
a little bit.
So it might just turn out
to be familiar for you.
And let's just look.
Let's just go back quickly and
revisit that elevator problem.
So you remember you're here.
You've got some mass m.
You're standing on some scales.
And I want to know what the
scales are going to read.
Now, we did this one
quickly the other day.
I'm just going to revisit it.
And this accelerating,
this is point A.
And here down here is o.
My inertial frame.
And the acceleration
of A with respect to o
is plus a quarter of g
in the j hat direction.
OK?
Now, when you think
about this, if you're
trying to do physics
in the elevator,
but it's an accelerating frame,
so Newton's laws don't apply.
So you're in the elevator.
You can't see
you're accelerating.
But you could measure
your weight, for example.
So how do you fix
up the equations
so that you can predict
the right answer?
And to do that, basically
you I have to add in a force,
a fictitious force,
that accounts
for the additional
forces you will
feel in this system due
to the acceleration.
So remember the way
we did this problem.
You do this problem just
in a straightforward
way, a summation of the external
forces in the y direction
is the mass times acceleration,
a with respect to o.
And we need a free body diagram.
In the free body
diagrams, this mass here,
you have an mg downwards
and an n upwards.
And so you'd say this
is equal to n minus mg.
Now, if you're doing
this experiment inside,
you can measure this n that's
going to be your weight.
And you would like to do
this by fictitious forces,
you say that the summation
of the external real forces
minus this mass times the
acceleration of a with respect
to o has got to be equal to 0.
And that's then n minus
mg minus mg over 4.
Here's your fictitious force.
And that's as if then
you've come over here
and you've added an additional
force on this free body diagram
that looks like mg over 4.
And now you say the sum of these
forces, this is the correction.
It's allowing you now to work
in this accelerating frame.
If do this free body
diagram and sum these up,
then you will find
this expression,
which you can solve for n.
And you'll get m5 over 4g.
In fact, if you stood on the
scales, that's what you'd get.
All right, so this
is example one.
I want to do sort
of example 1.5.
The cable breaks
on this elevator.
Your free body diagram
still has an mg on it.
You're still inside.
You're still measuring forces.
And you want to use this
idea of a fictitious force
to help you sort out
what forces will you
feel inside of that elevator.
You know how to do the answer
in this straightforward way.
The sum of external
forces is minus mg.
And that's equal to the
mass times the acceleration
of a with respect to o.
And therefore acceleration
of a with respect to o
is just minus g.
And you could have told me that.
That's trivial.
If you drop the thing, it
accelerates the acceleration
of gravity.
So I want to know
what's the-- you're
doing the experiment inside.
You don't know that
you're accelerating.
All you're doing
is measurements.
But you've been told
how to correct it.
So let's put it in the
fictitious force, which
is minus ma 0.
And that means the mass times
acceleration is downwards.
So minus that.
The fictitious force
is an mg force upwards.
And what do you feel?
What do the scales read?
Nothing.
You feel absolutely nothing.
OK.
So just an aside kind of
question, because I know this
is confused.
Occasionally we all get
confused around this.
In these problems that we do,
is gravity an acceleration?
We say all the time,
I use the phrase
the acceleration of gravity.
How many times have
you ever said that?
Have you ever said that?
The acceleration of gravity.
What do we mean?
What we mean is this.
When you let something
drop in free fall,
it'll accelerate at g.
But the way we apply when
we're writing out equations
of motion, we say the sum
of the external forces
is equal to mass
times acceleration.
Where does gravity go?
It's a force.
So this is another
thing not to get
confused by is to think
about gravity as being
an acceleration.
We spend a lot of
time figuring out ways
to write accelerations
in rotating,
translating, reference frames.
Gravity never pops up in there.
It always comes up on the
force side of the equation.
OK.
All right, so one last
example from last time.
But it's relevant to a
problem on the homework.
So we have this shaft spinning.
This is the z-axis spinning
at constant rate omega.
And we'll use this is r
hat and this is z k hat.
These are the lengths r hat
direction and the height z.
We're using cylindrical
coordinates.
And now let's just use this
notion of fictitious forces
to figure out first
what's the what's
the fictitious force
in this system.
Remember, this is now
this notion of you're
out there where this mass is.
You're riding with this mass.
And you're trying to say,
what force am I going to feel?
You want to be able to
predict it correctly.
So you have to find
a fictitious force
that you can bring in
that accounts for what
acceleration are we
feeling out there.
Centripetal, right?
And the centripetal
acceleration,
we want the sum of
the external forces.
And this is going
to be in the r hat
direction minus m
times the-- and now we
need reference frames here.
So you have a fixed frame o xy.
You have a rotating frame here,
a x prime, y prime, z prime.
And this is your
point b up here.
So some of the external
forces minus the mass
times the acceleration
of b with respect to 0
has got to be equal to 0.
That's how this fictitious
force thing works.
So on the free body
diagram of this thing,
what are the actual
forces on it?
Well, there's certainly
a weight downwards.
There must be some
supporting force upwards.
And we'll put that in
the z direction here.
Because this thing certainly
doesn't accelerate up and down.
So the rods lifting
it up somehow.
The rod has potentially
some radial component.
And I'm just drawing it
in the positive direction.
And those are my forces.
And in this problem,
omega dot theta double dot
equals 0 and r dot and
r double dot were 0.
So it's constant rotation rate.
No geometry changes here.
So we did, we cranked
through this problem before.
And now I wanted to
make this correction.
I want to add this
fictitious force in.
The acceleration
is minus r omega
squared in the r hat direction.
So minus m times that is a plus.
I get an m r omega squared.
And pointing outwards.
And so the sum of the forces
in the radial direction
minus-- some of the forces
in the radial direction now
minus this mab
with respect to o.
Well, what are some
of the real forces?
Just nr.
And this minus mass times the
acceleration, that's your mr
squared.
mr omega squared.
And that's got to be 0.
So you find out
that there is a--
This all is 0.
Therefore solve for nr is
minus mr omega squared.
So that rod out here is
constantly pulling it in
to make it go around the circle.
But we've just done
this now by this notion
of a fictitious force.
So let's go back to
this problem now.
Well actually, I'll just
take one final step.
Here's your free body
diagram touched up
with this fictitious
force so that we
can work as if we're here.
And by the way, if
you could measure,
if you had a strain
gauge or something
so you can measure the
force that this rod
is putting on that mass.
If you can measure
it out there, this
would be what you would measure.
Now what about the torque that
force creates around here?
So you have outward
force mr omega
squared at centrifugal
force, this fictitious force.
Going pulling it out up here.
What moment does that
create down here?
What's the magnitude first?
And that'll be a torque
around in the theta direction.
So what's the moment arm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The moment arm?
The moment arm.
z.
OK.
So then the torque is
going to be 4r cross f
and it's going to be
the mrz omega squared.
And it's at centripetal
forces trying to bend it out.
Therefore the torque
down here required
to keep it from
doing so is actually
in the other direction.
So the torque that this system
must put on this bar is minus.
OK.
So let's go to this problem.
If this is the point about which
we're computing the moments,
then there's centripetal
acceleration in this problem,
but in what direction are they?
Either one of those masses.
Pardon?
So each little mass, like
the upper mass m over 2.
It's spinning and it's shown as
it's coming around the wheel.
It's up at the top.
What direction is
the fictitious force
that it's putting
on that system?
Radial outwards, right?
And does it have
any moment arm that
force going up with respect
to that point in the center?
No.
So it creates no moment.
The bottom one by
symmetry doesn't either.
This one over here, it
also has a fictitious force
you can think of.
It's just outward
mr omega squared.
What's its moment arm with
respect to our origin here?
0.
Again, it produces no moment.
It produces an unbalanced
force though, right?
It's going around producing
an unbalanced force.
This problem, the upper ones,
the fictitious force is up.
The lower one, which
direction is it?
Down.
It's perfectly balanced.
They're just equal and
opposite, just going around.
You'd feel nothing
uncomfortable.
This one you'd feel, this
motorcycle trying to hop down.
It really happens, right?
But this one, what happens?
Does this mass m over
2, what direction is
the centripetal acceleration?
I've changed the
wording a little bit.
The upper mass in case
b, which direction
is the centripetal acceleration?
Straight down, right?
And the bottom mass,
what direction?
Straight up.
And the fictitious
forces that reflect
those two accelerations
are the top one is up
and the bottom one is down.
But they produce a net.
Do they have a moment arm
that they act on with respect
to that center?
Yeah, this little distance here.
I think it's called
b in the problem.
So this thing, m over 2
r omega squared times b,
is a torque about the x-axis.
And this one down
here is another m
over 2 r omega squared
and it's another torque
in the same direction.
So this thing produces
quite a strong moment.
But as the wheel turns,
that moment starts off,
it's about the x-axis here.
But when that weight
gets to 90 degrees,
what direction is the moment?
So we just do all the
way around the y-axis.
So it's going to be a moment.
The answer to this
problem is in time
it's going to look something
like mr omega squared z
sine or cosine omega t.
So the moment in this
around the x-axis
is going to be trying to--
the bike's going to try
to go back and forth like this.
With frequency omega.
OK.
Oh, I was going to say that's
it for fictitious forces,
but it's not.
I've got a great demo for you.
All right.
We have a slope.
I've got a cart on wheels there.
And I actually do.
OK.
And I'm going to put a box here.
I got the wrong
color here, but I'll
try colored chalk
for the first time.
In the box I've got a fluid.
And the box has a lid on
it so I don't make a mess.
Now, I'm actually going
to do this experiment.
I brought my ramp.
We're going to set up this ramp.
This box is going to be
rolling down this hill.
And basically no losses.
No friction holding it back.
It's just going to be able to
take off and accelerate down
that hill.
I want to know a, b, c.
When it's rolling down that
hill, will the fluid in the box
look like that, look
like that, or like that?
So we're going to
take our poll here.
So how many believe that when
it's rolling down the hill,
the fluid will stay level,
parallel to the ground?
Let's raise your hands.
I want everybody to
make a guess here.
Everybody get in it.
Raise them high if you think
it's going to stay level.
OK, maybe a quarter of you.
How many think it's
going to do this?
OK, a few more.
And how many think
it's going to do this?
All right, so I want you get
in natural little groups there
of two or three people and talk
about this for a couple minutes
and see if you can convince
your neighbor that you're right.
Figure this out.
Stop and talk about it.
And let's set up to
do the experiment.
Actually, I think
if we do it up here.
Yeah.
So like that.
So you hold the ramp.
OK, you come here.
We'll just practice our
set up here for a second.
You're going to have to
hold it quite a bit higher.
And actually when
we get ready to go--
AUDIENCE: How well
sealed is that?
PROFESSOR: It's
very well sealed.
You hold it and you release it.
And that's about the right--
because I got to catch it so it
doesn't-- now,
we're going to stop.
We're not going to
do it right away.
I'm going to get them to answer
the question a second time.
Good idea.
All right.
And I think that'll
work just great.
And we're not going
to give it away.
OK, so set it down and
we'll do the thing.
Just drop it.
OK, let's do the quiz again.
I want to see if any of
you convinced your neighbor
to change their vote.
So how many believe
that it's going to be A?
Hm, one or two.
Interesting, that
kind of went down.
How many believe
it's going to be B?
A lot of people went up.
How many think
it's going to be C?
OK, still a couple hold outs.
Let's do the experiment.
So guys in the booth, can
you get a good shot of this,
I hope?
I want this so it [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
Move the chalk.
Yep.
And I'm going to
have to catch it.
All right.
Let her rip.
Which way?
AUDIENCE: B.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Let's do it again.
Just make sure the guys in the
booth got a good shot of this.
OK, once more.
Pretty neat, huh?
If you're skiing downhill,
you're going down the hill,
accelerating, which way do you
feel the forces on your body?
You feel the forces
pulling you down straight?
Do you feel the forces
pulling you down the hill?
pulling you into the hill?
So this is straightforward
application of this.
The slope of that liquid
was parallel to the slope.
Get my notes back out here.
So let's quickly do
this problem rigorously,
the way we'd do
it straightforward
with accelerations and free
body diagrams and so forth.
We're going to have some
normal force pushing up.
I said no friction.
This thing's a slippery surface,
just as if it's sliding down.
Got to do rollers
in the classroom.
It's got an mg.
And there are no
other external forces.
And we know then
that the summation
of the external
forces, that's got
to be the mass times
the acceleration.
And I'm going to make this here.
I'll call this point
A in the center.
And I'm going to make
my inertial reference
frame x down the hill, y
perpendicular to the hill.
So the mass times the
acceleration of a with respect
to o is then equal.
And this is my then
external forces.
So this is my x direction.
So I'm going to break this and
mg force into two components.
One down the hill.
Guess I need an angle.
Let's see.
So if this is theta,
then this is theta here.
And the force down the
hill is that component
is mg sine theta.
And the force this direction
is then going to be.
And I'll just give us
some unit vectors here
to keep things straight.
This force is minus mg cosine
theta in the j hat direction.
So the sum of the forces
here, all of them,
are mg sine theta i hat
minus mg cosine theta j hat
plus n in the j hat direction.
So that's the total vector sum.
And that's got to be equal to
my mass times the acceleration
of a with respect to o.
And we know that's
straight down the hill.
So this one's only going to
be in the i hat direction.
We know the acceleration
perpendicular
hill has got to be 0.
OK, so if we just add up the
components of this thing.
In the i hat direction,
just the x direction,
then I have only this
term and that term.
And I find that the
mg sine theta equals.
And so the acceleration
of a with respect to o
is just g sine theta.
OK, well that's pretty trivial.
And it doesn't give us
much insight about-- that
doesn't give me much insight
about why that's the answer.
So actually this is a
time when maybe thinking
about if you're in that free,
you're going down the hill,
you're skiing, and you're now
in an accelerating reference
frame, and you
want to say I want
to work from this frame,
what fictitious force do
I have to add to that
free body diagram
so I can account
for my acceleration?
So remember the
fictitious force we
want to deal with has
to do with this guy.
We're in the moving frame.
We can't judge this.
We're just told that it exists
and we need to correct for it.
So we need a
fictitious force that's
minus ma with respect to o.
So that would be
minus mg sine theta.
And that would be
in this direction.
So dashed lines here is my mg
sine theta fictitious force.
In the other direction was
the real force, the component
of gravity mg sine theta.
In this direction
was my normal force.
And in this direction is
my component of gravity
that is my mg cosine theta.
It's a real force.
So yeah, these real forces
and this fictitious force.
But now we can say that all
these forces have to sum to 0.
But look what happens here.
What force do you feel?
In the reference frame, you're
the skier going down the hill.
What net forces do you feel on
you that are in the x direction
down the hill?
0.
It's exactly.
The reason I did that silly
free fall problem a minute
ago when you drop something,
when you're weightless,
the scales are reading-- the
cable broke in the elevator,
scales read 0.
The fictitious force
was equal and opposite
to the gravitational
force you feel
and the scales would show
no force in the free fall
direction.
In this case, you're
not free fall,
but you're free
fall down a slope.
In the component
down the slope, you
have no net force
in that direction.
In the reference frame
that moving cart,
the only actual
force you feel is in.
You will feel a force on your
feet equal to mg cosine theta.
So if theta goes to 90
degrees, you're in free fall,
and it goes to 0.
Say it is 0 degrees, it's
max, and you would feel mg.
This is [INAUDIBLE]
me where this notion
of a fictitious
force kind of helps
me figure out what's going on.
Pretty amazing.
OK.
So we're going to move on
from this kind of discussion
of fictitious forces of things.
So it's been an hour.
We'll take a little
break for a second.
Also, if you've
got any questions
about what we've covered up to
this point, think about them
and ask them in a minute.
Let's take a short break.
So while you've been taking
a break, a couple of people
came up and asked questions.
One of them was, are
fictitious forces real?
And the other is, why
does the water move?
So the answer to
the first question.
If you want to be careful and
do the problem rigorously,
don't mess with
fictitious forces.
The only real forces
in the problem
are the ones that you would put
on a free body diagram, such
that the sum of
the external forces
equals the mass
times acceleration.
These forces are
always real ones.
They are gravity.
They are normal forces.
They're friction.
They're spring forces.
They're dashpot forces.
They're all these
mechanical things,
but they're real forces.
And the rod, that
thing spinning around,
that rod, since it's a rigid
thing, it can support bending.
So it has shear
force, axial forces.
Those are real forces that
it can put on the mass.
Fictitious forces
are not forces.
They are minus a mass
times a real what?
Acceleration.
So real forces,
real accelerations.
We use this notion
of a fictitious force
as a convenience.
But it is a highly
dangerous tool.
But actually once you get
used to it a little bit,
it can give you some
really quick insight.
But I would always, if I have
doubts, I'd always go back
and just do the problem
the rigorous way and just
check that your
insight was right.
But it can give you a great
insight to starting a problem.
You know to expect a centrifugal
term in your results.
You know to expect
a Coriolis term.
You know that they're going to
be there because sometimes you
feel them.
The reason we like to use
them is because you actually
can feel them.
They actually affect
what you feel.
So in that first problem, the
elevator problem, the answer--
I didn't actually write it.
Here it is.
The normal force that you
feel, that the scale weighs
is 5 force g.
And it's the sum of gravity
and that fictitious force.
It's mg plus m times
a quarter of a g.
It's in this moving references,
this accelerator reference
frame inside an elevator
where you can't directly
measure the acceleration.
All you can measure
is the force.
But you know what
the acceleration is.
It's given.
So you stick it in as
a fix and you find out
that the real normal force
that you measure actually has
in it that piece comes
from the fictitious force.
OK.
Why does the water move?
This is really the
same discussion.
The fictitious force up
the hill and the real force
down the hill exactly cancel.
If you're standing on
scales, it actually
can measure side force
as well as normal force.
Standing on the scales, you
would feel no side forces
up and down the hill.
None.
You measure a normal force and
the normal force you measure
will be mg cosine theta.
So the force on any object in
that accelerating reference
frame, it essentially
thinks that all forces are
perpendicular, that you feel
in that reference frame,
are perpendicular to the hill.
So why does water seek level?
Because the force
gravity is down
and the surface of the
water goes perpendicular
to the gravitational force.
That's just the
nature of fluids.
So if the force on all those
fluid particles is this angle,
what's the fluid
level going to do?
So that the pressure on the
surface is equal everywhere.
And if you go a foot down,
you get equal pressure
everywhere in the fluid.
So the water moves
so that its surface
will be perpendicular
to what it thinks.
It thinks that this is kind
of being a local gravity.
The local gravity is
pointed in that direction,
so the surface level
seeks that level.
If somebody else can
say it better than that.
Tom, Dave, Matt, anybody?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can I
ask you a question?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, as
if you're on the body
and you're trying to sum
up all the forces you feel
and accounting also for the
fact that this is accelerating.
And the fix it force is
this fictitious force that's
due to the body's acceleration.
You have to know that
you're accelerating
to be able to put this term in.
And it comes from this
equation, thinking
of this as a generic
equation by taking this term
and just moving it to
this side and setting
everything equal to 0.
Lots of puzzlement around this.
AUDIENCE: What happens if you
make the angle of the ramp very
steep?
PROFESSOR: Very steep.
So if it goes to 90 degrees,
you're in free fall.
This cosine theta goes
to 0, n goes to 0.
This term stays the same.
This goes to mg that way.
This goes mg that way.
And it's an
equilibrium in both--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Then
you're going to have
very, very small, normal force.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I couldn't
hear the last comment.
AUDIENCE: The water wouldn't
go all the way to the side.
It'd be vertical
length [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well,
water, unfortunately,
with the tiniest little
bit of normal force here
the water will seek that level.
But when it gets to 0 the water
is going to be in free fall.
Surface tension takes over.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this like the
argument that [INAUDIBLE]
is the same as if it was just
on a flat surface accelerating?
PROFESSOR: Oh, good question.
If you were on a flat
surface accelerating.
If you were accelerating
in this cart.
Accelerates with the
fluid on it and it's
accelerating in
that direction, what
would the surface
of the liquid do?
Stay level or change?
OK, does it slope back
or does it slope forward?
I'm accelerating
in that direction.
There's a fictitious
force pushing back on it,
makes it pile up at the back.
OK one more.
You're in the elevator.
You're accelerating
a quarter of a g.
The scales tells you you weigh
25% more than you used to.
And you have a pendulum.
And before the
elevator starts, it's
got a one second natural period.
And now the elevator gets going.
Does the period change?
Higher or lower?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so
the natural frequency
of the pendulum, simple pendulum
square root of g over l.
What do you guess that the
natural frequency is if you're
going up at a quarter of a g?
Say again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's as if you have
a higher or lower acceleration
of gravity around.
But you have a higher
gravitational force
is what you think
you're feeling.
Is that going to make the
tension in this string higher?
Is that going to make the weight
of the pendulum feel greater?
Yeah, by 5 force.
And you'll find out,
you'll work out.
It gets kind of messy to
prove this rigorously,
but it's going to look something
like the square root of 5/4
g over l.
OK.
We've got a little time left.
I might not be able to
completely finish this.
But I do want to
show you something.
Hold it up so they can see it.
Gets pretty violent, doesn't it?
Pass it around.
OK.
This thing is
shaking like crazy.
All right.
In the absence of
external forces,
what can you say about
the motion of its center
of gravity, do you think?
In at least this direction.
Can't move, right?
Up and down direction
the center of gravity
does move, because I'm putting
a force on it through the cord.
This has a relation
to a problem that you
had on problem set two.
I want to go back and talk
about it a little bit.
And this is that thing
with the track in it.
And a roller going around.
And it's going to around
at constant speed.
And this has mass m.
This is mass.
The outside thing is just
the mass of this block.
And there's an internal
donut in here, [INAUDIBLE],
and this mass is made
to go around and around
and around and around inside.
And you were asked to figure out
the acceleration of that guy.
But this thing's on wheels.
Now, this problem,
and I apologize
for posing this
problem the way I did.
I should have posed
in the following way.
These two problems are
really equal to one another.
I have a rod.
I have a mass on the end.
This radius here we said was e.
This radius is e.
The mass is the same.
It's m.
This was going around at omega.
This is going around at omega.
This is on wheels.
Exactly these two
problems are identical.
Because if the
geometry's the same,
the rotation rate's
the same, the masses
are the same, the acceleration
of this bead here,
this roller is the
same in this problem
as it is in that problem.
Just in this problem
it's much easier
to figure out the forces.
This turned out to
be kind of nasty.
And I said last time
that the solution
to b part, which is the
normal force that this
is put on this roller, I
said that answer was wrong.
I actually am wrong about that.
I was thinking of
a different answer.
I was thinking of this problem.
The answer that was given,
the normal force that
is by the track places
on the roller or vice
versa is actually what
was given is correct.
It wasn't what I
actually was seeking
when I wrote the problem.
Sometimes when you're
making up problems,
you have an end result in mind
and then you wrote it wrong.
I wrote it wrong.
So let's do this problem.
This is partly to review a
couple of things for you.
What I really want is I want
to find equation of motion
in-- [INAUDIBLE].
So here's my xyz
inertial reference frame.
I just lined it up
here with the center
of this thing to start with.
Doesn't really matter.
So I want to find an equation
of motion in the x direction.
We don't have time to do
this whole problem here,
so I'm going to do
the first piece of it.
Just to give you some review,
an exercise in figuring out
degrees of freedom.
I'm implying that I
can write one equation.
It may take more than that.
So the number of degrees
of freedom we said
is equal to the
number of required--
I can't write today--
independent coordinates.
So the number of coordinates
required to completely describe
the motion.
And we came up a little
expression for that.
It's 6 times the
number rigid bodies
plus 3 times the
number of particles.
So this is rigid bodies.
This is particles.
Minus c.
And these are the constraints.
So let's figure that
out for this problem.
So how many constraints?
It's just a quick practice.
So constraints and
I'm going to start off
with on the main block.
So on the main block,
there's no y motion.
There's no z motion.
These rollers don't
let it come in or out.
So no y or z motion.
So that's two constraints.
What about rotations
on the main block?
How many constraints
are we assuming here?
Three.
We're not allowing it the
role in x, the y, or the z.
So there's three
more constraints.
And now on the little mass.
On the little mass,
there's no z motion.
That's out of the board.
That's one more constraint.
And then omega t is the
angle that this thing.
It's theta.
This is specified.
It's a given in the problem.
It's not unknown.
It's just that's
what's going, that's
what makes this
thing do its thing.
It's going round and round.
And so this is not an unknown.
And therefore you can say that
the y motion of this particle
is e sine omega t.
And that's a constraint.
And the x motion is the
motion of the main block
to which it's attached
plus an e cosine omega t.
And these are knowns.
You've already counted for this.
That's the main mass's motion.
So this is something known.
So these mount up,
each one of these.
This gives you a constraint and
this gives you a constraint.
And so let's add them up.
So 2 and 3 are 5.
6, 7, 8.
So you can actually
completely describe
the motion of this thing
with one equation of motion.
So I'm seeking.
So I want to find the sum
of the external forces
on the main block
in the x direction.
And that's going to be.
We know that that's the mass of
that block times x double dot.
So x is going to be the
coordinate that describes
the motion that mass mb.
So we need a free
body diagram of mb.
So here's the block.
There'll be a normal force up.
There's going to
be mbg downwards.
And the only other forces
acting on this block
are a force that comes through
this rod that's holding
that mass, the little mass.
I'm just going to draw it
at some arbitrary angle,
not necessarily theta.
It's going to be a force.
I'm going to call that
force on this main mass.
And it's a vector
for the moment.
It'll have two components
in the x and y directions.
So in order to write an
equation-- in the y direction
it's trivial. n is equal to mbg.
In this direction, we
have to have to break this
into two components.
We need to know the component
of this in the x direction
and put it in here
and we'll be done.
So now I'm going
to use third law.
The force that rod
places on this body
is equal and opposite
to the force at the rod
places on the mass
going round and round.
You agree with me?
So what we need to
do next is here's
the mass up here going
around and round.
And the force is on it,
because it has an mg downward.
And it has some
force on it that is
the force on the little mass.
And you're going to find
that f on the little mass
equals minus f on the big mass
due to third law consideration.
So all I have to do
is then figure out
the x component of this force,
put a minus sign in front
of it, and I'm basically done.
And to do that I
say f equals ma.
I don't have to finish it today.
I'll show you next time.
And we'll figure out
the equation of motion
for this thing.
Now, in dragging all
this stuff here today,
I forgot to bring
my muddy cards.
So you've got a minute.
And if any of you have
just a brilliant question
you want to answer or
something you really
liked, if you don't mind,
just take a piece of paper,
make a note on it, and
drop it off on the way out.
Thanks a lot.
See you on Thursday.